28 year old right hander eric fetty two
career starts against the jays 1-0
record 2.89 era
swinging a miss fetty gets him with the
off speed stuff here's the matchup
vladimir guerrero jr there is the ground
ball through the vacated right side and
vlady jr is a two-out base runner well
that's one of the reasons why he's
hitting 314. for pitch walk to oscar is
on board
dickerson likes the 3-1 it's up the
middle a little step on the bag to
retire this side big rookie alec manoa
is on the mound and there's really not
much of a debate over who the best
rookie starting pitcher is in the
american league you're looking at him i
know his first pitch swung on and popped
up backing up marcus simeon shallow and
right field underneath it all alone to
make the play this is the premier
matchup of the night manoa against soto
and he rings up soto
wow what a pitch nasty 2c fastball a la
greg maddox tremendous pitch locks up
one of the best hitters in the game and
sits down the side in order with a nine
pitch burst this is the 33 year old
rookie from cuba one of the clubhouse
favorites yadiel hernandez
and he connects on the o2 drives it to
deep right and it is gone
yadiel hernandez muscles up on an 02
pitch to put the nationals on the board
first home run number five on the season
his manager says he has sneaky pop and
he snuck one just over the wall
in right field into the nat's bullpen
carter keyboard with another base head
here comes luis garcia
on the ground this could be two semi
into bashed firing to guerrero junior
and they will double them up and retire
the side runners on it first and second
here comes to oscar hernandez
say oscar off of betty's glove and it
looks like it's going to turn itself
into an infield hit and it is although
josh bell wants it reviewed pachette to
third guerrero jr up to second it was
close to oscar hernandez with an
absolute rocket that was halted a bit by
fetty it's just a reactionary play when
you're a pitcher all your momentum is
going towards home plate here's a good
look at it right here this ball
fortunately it's hit at his glove side
which knocks it down a great play by
garcia almost like that soccer guy that
scores a goal watch this slide right
here
looks like he's out too yeah i think
this one's going to be overturned too
scott that's pretty good
but now standing over at third guerrero
jr at second here comes corey dickerson
who's hope for one
and this time to the right side it'll
bring home a run fetty covering first
dickerson is out but
pachette scores and evens up the game at
one a piece an rbi ground out for corey
dickerson guerrero's at third here's
grichik
and grichik makes contact it's bell it's
fetty it's the same play again
and that will do it for the third victor
robles was just hit by a pitch that'll
move up riley adams to second adams let
off the third inning with a hit escobar
coming up next
escobar is going to find some open space
and he comes through
adam's come on down
row blaze come on down that'll bring two
in for the nationals and make it 3-1 on
the escobar 2 rbi double two-seam
fastball intended to be in it was up
escobar drives this right into that
vacated gap there in left center field
speed of roblox he scores all the way
from first alec bono laboring a bit now
as the nationals have seemed to crack
the code so far that doesn't get any
easier here yadiel hernandez homered off
manoa
and he is swinging it's on the ground
it's a tough play for beshet it gets
past him in comes escobar and soto will
score and the throw to third is not in
time bell is in there it's a two rbi hit
for yadiel hernandez he's driven in
three tonight to make it 5-1 nationals
good job by josh bell being aggressive
to get from first to third and that's
still in business
and that one sails away and that will
score another run
josh bell will walk home
and hernandez goes first to third manoa
unraveling
in the third and now he's giving up a
career high six runs tonight yeah this
is this is unfortunately what happens
when you have a young pitcher not a very
good lead really no reason to go over
there and pick at first base now you're
in damage control mode man on third one
out
blast one deep left field dickerson
looking forward he has some room and he
makes the catch but that will drive in
another run
a sac flight almost left the yard for ki
boom and it's 7-1 washington trent
thornton is going to take over now for
alec manoa who was pinch hit for in the
previous half inning riley adams is one
for one talking about big home runs
riley adams go long he muscles up for a
solo shot it's 8-1 washington second of
the season for adams who was picked up
in the brad hand trade with the blue
jays pretty good night for riley adams
glad he walks for a second time tonight
he's reached base in all three plate
appearances there's oscar hernandez
swinging on the first pitch driving it
deep to center it's got a lot of lift to
it and it is gone
to oscar continues to light up the
baseball and he makes it 8-3 on his 21st
home run of the season well that was a
no-doubter high towering fly ball to
center field hernandez hits this one
looked like way up to the moon victor
robles gets back but he has no chance in
the blue jays
trying to claw back third straight game
with a homer for hernandez now dickerson
hard on the ground gobbled up by bell
and he'll toss it over to fetty for the
out that's it for the inning but the
oscar hernandez strikes again bags full
of blue jays in the eighth a hitting two
walks to start the inning this is a guy
you want in he's probably been their
most reliable guy coming out of the
bullpen kyle finnegan has been all on
the ground uh that should be two to
trade the run for double play no
espional saving first
in comes hernandez to make it an 8-4
game and they just get the fielder's
choice at second base to put runners on
the corners with just one down in the
eight and gives the blue jays two outs
to play with here in the eighth
maguire spits one on the ground and it's
bobbled by garcia gets past him and
brings in another run dickerson will
score maguire reaches on the e4 and the
inning continues with just one out in
the eighth it's 8-5 kirk with runners on
the corners up the middle base hit
that's another one for the blue jays
it's 8-6
semion in the air and
soto's trotting in
and it's not going to do much to gone in
the eighth
right to second for garcia and he's
going to go to first
thought about a little underhand toss to
second or even going there himself that
could have been a world of trouble to
keep the inning going this game is
tightened up juan soto will lead off in
the home eighth
and soto connects solidly into the gap
in right center
and he's heading for two easily stand up
double to lead off this home eighth for
the nationals you know there's so many
good young left-handed hitters in the
game of baseball but you're looking at
the best of the bunch right here 116
miles an hour off the bat the exit
velocity for juan soto and this is an
8-6 game
bases are loaded up for the gnats
saucedo is replaced by raphael dolis as
charlie montoya opts for the
right-handed pitcher against ryan
zimmerman
there it is
deep drive left field warning track
not enough to bring home everyone but it
will score a key insurance run for the
nationals juan soto scores
and makes it 9-6 now zim does his job in
a pinch hitting roll they're on the
corners for riley adams who homered
earlier tonight
adams to right and the gnats do add on
lane thomas is in
and now ki boom wing waved around some
trouble in right field then that's get
another run and break it back open it's
11-6 what a night for riley adams to
catch her in the eighth spot boy he's
had some kind of a knight third hit on
the night
a couple of big insurance runs
row blaze past third and here comes
another for the nationals riley adams
will score and make it 12-6 and nats are
one out away from picking up a w tonight
on the ground and this should do it
game over
nationals take it 12-6 in d.c
[Applause]
you